so
some of it lunch yes oh they're so cute but
they're just they have they like the curls thank
you my name is griffin mcconnell i i was born in
the september 2004. my life story's been a very
up and down kind of thing it's like you you think
it's gonna be good and then everything collapses
i know i have seizures i it
stinks that i have seizures
that's very lovely i was diagnosed with
epilepsy when i was i think five yes
when he was four before all the medical
stuff started happening we had one of those
goofy ten and one games that was like chinese
checkers and you know and checkers and it also
was chess and griffin asked me to teach him how
to play chess it was very funny the chess was
kind of a major part of my surgeries because it
was memorizing and i wanted to figure out what
this game was and so when time passed my chest was
getting better but also my seizures were getting
worse and he was sitting in the car and
he wouldn't respond to me and i started
yelling at him griffin what's wrong come on we
gotta go and it was just weird we tried to do
medicine and we tried to do use a lot of drugs
to make my seizures come down but it didn't work
when you fail enough of the medicines then you
finally become a candidate for brain surgery
that's what you called it let's see it bring it
he had his first two brain surgeries in
2012. one was a grid surgery where they
take the grid and stick it straight onto the
brain and then try to figure out where those
seizures are coming from a year later he had a
left functional hemispherectomy which is where
they disconnect the two sides of the brain and
take out some of the tissue in the left hemisphere
chess has played a huge role in
this family we're not doing this
no we're pulling bullet chests that's what
that's that's just means
that if you're white you lose
chess is always a passion of mine i've done it a
long time and so after the left hemispherectomy
i started to regain my thinking and my abilities
why am i moving so fast
yes
i did try to um play chess like
we've mentioned but like i i just
i thought well i did it for a couple reasons just
to see try something new to see if i liked it also
to try to get a little closer with my brothers
because i mean we're close but like sully and
griffin are much closer than me i just sent you
a challenge sullivan i have your face in there
he was really happy to play again because
he'd lost playing chess for about a year
um and he'll tell you about this he feels like
that's where sullivan his younger brother cheated
him and got ahead of him in raiding because
sullivan kept playing griffin couldn't we
played a lot before griffin uh was disabled
and we still play a lot after he was disabled
really the hardest the hard part of my brother's
disability is that really he can do everything i
can except it just takes him more time okay
hold on uh all right quickly i'm going to
check that out that actually i think that
was a fortress it's time to check hold on
let's see was that correct was it
a fortress oh my god it is it is
okay like wait i played that like so terribly
so how did i what after knight c too i have i'm
okay so i have to play griffin made expert when he
was 12. and then he's just been stuck uh on expert
which is he's really pushing to make master and
part of that i think is because he was also trying
to learn how to read and write and do school
so trying to take all that brain power when you
only have half of the brain to do all of that
i think is partly why he hasn't gotten as fast
a big part of chess is everyone has an ego and
everyone if they want to learn how to play chess
they have to know they they're going to lose
honestly you've got to give nakamura a great
deal of credit on chess.com because and i'm not
saying that to suck up to chess.com either but
god love them because they're doing these these
new tournaments these pog championships have you
watched any of those oh you should have yeah
they're all even kind of things so they have
non-chess players but they're really great uh
at fortnight or they're really great and they
have a bunch of followers on another platform
and they they pair them with a nakamura or a
you know a high rated player and that player works
with them for like 20 30 days you know gets them
to a 1200 level or something they're there of
and then they have a championship where they
play and nakamura just does comments understand
why he made those moves but isn't it what you
said before about like this this cycle where it's
like when you're when the other guy's moving fast
you move fast when they're moving you move
slower and so you know you're just watching
rank amateurs play chess and it's hilarious
because they miss easy checkmates they blunder
pieces right and left but they're really serious
about it so like the guy who played the mountain
on a game of thrones uh he's a chess player now
he was in the last pog championships and there's
i mean there's something really enthralling
about watching someone of his stature and size
hunkered down you know making you know cussing
because he missed a fork you know or whatever
uh okay it didn't start well uh but it's
going well now he's taking the center
uh i'm just gonna castle i'm just gonna castle
here i like that i like that i like castling yeah
bringing my pieces to the center uh
staying calm he does this in our lessons
okay at six o'clock on this saturday
uh you are going to have a interview
with hikaru nakamura in the interview yes
he's going to zoom you're going to have
a zoom call just with the karo nakamura what
yes that's a lot of pressure on me i love carl
i'm his biggest fan team has entered the
waiting room for this meeting so should i accept
so i say omit is that what it is okay i'm
ready can you hear me now yes what's up
good good good um i uh i'm feeling pretty nervous
but that's kind of cool when your favorite person
is hakaro nakamura so i'm very excited but nervous
you know what i mean so all right cool so um
do you have any like least favorite part about
chess for a long time i feel like it's sort of
been like we we idolize these top players we try
to say how smart the top players are at the game
of chess instead of just uh instead of trying
to be inclusive saying well it's you know there
might be people who are really good at it but
anybody can play the game you don't have to be
smart to be good at it but a lot of people sort
of they they figure well if you're if you're not
a great shots for then who cares like you know it
doesn't matter so you start judging the self-worth
or what someone what someone does based on their
rating instead of just being a person thank you
very much hakaro um no problem i'm just uh it's
exciting you know what i mean yeah no that's
which which olympia did you play in though i'm
kind of curious now he played in the olympia the
online olympiad um which was the very first
ever online olympiad for people with uh dis
disabilities colorado is not it's not it's not
big for people with disabilities who play chess
griffin had a tremendous tournament in spite of
having seizures he was bored two and he scored
a four out of seven points which is every
single person he played was at least 150 to uh
400 points higher rated than him that was the
point um where i wanted to be something to inspire
a great icon for me is thomas luther he's
a grandmaster but he has a disability
and he is trying to create all of
these tournaments that i've been
into and so for me i want to be like thomas luther
he went six years seizure-free we think
and now he's having seizures again
it was kind of heartbreaking because i was
doing so many things like wonderful things
and now it came back one of the games he lost
quite badly he had a seizure the last eight
minutes of the game the problem is that there's
a clock ticking and so all of a sudden my time
went to 15 minutes to 5 minutes out of nowhere and
so these seizures are really messing up my play
there's a surgery coming up and
we're trying well griffin dad and mom
are trying to decide whether they should do
it or they shouldn't he's going to go in for
an anatomical hemispherectomy which is they
take everything out of that left hemisphere
my biggest fear and i i think griffin's biggest
fear is that either he'll die in one because that
is always a possibility or he has to have this
brain surgery and it doesn't work i think that's
more scary than even him passing away
in the surgery is that it doesn't work
again in my opinion surgery is the only way
that i can feel like the seizures have been gone
i just hope that he and sally
stay happy with the chess because
they commit a lot of time and energy to test
so yeah i guess i just want them to be happy
griffin is a miracle to me and i just think
he's he's my hero and i try to be as good of
a person because he's so strong and he's taught
me a lot it's really hard to take anything else
super seriously i mean in terms of
the small stuff which is a blessing
right here
and if you made a mistake
you